bonjour à tous à suivre dans un instant
l'examen d'une proposition de loi
sénatoriale qui vise à la mise en place
d'une police territoriale police qui
fusionnerait le cadre d'emplois de
policier municipal et celui de garde
champêtre ce texte a été déposé par le
sénateur ump françois pillet ainsi que
par le sénateur socialiste rené
vandierendonck
ce texte est relativement consensuelle
il émane des propositions qu'il est
dessinateur avait faite à l'issue d'un
rapport qu'ils ont déposés en 2012
rapports et propositions qui ont ensuite
été assumée et reprises un manuel valls
fin 2013 lorsqu'il était ministre de
l'intérieur
alors le nouveau policier territoriale
pourra assumer la fonction de garde
champêtre ou de policier municipal qui
se mettent à niveau ce texte prévoit
également encourage la mise en place de
policiers intercommunaux voilà tout de
suite retour à la séance qui s'est
déroulée hier après midi au sénat la
parole est à françois pillet sénateur
ump qui ouvre donc la discussion
générale sur le président seul ministre
de la mer à porter que ce président de
la commission des lois mes chers
collègues la proposition de loi que nous
examinons cet après midi est né de
l'analyse des très nombreuses auditions
consultation et observations faites à
l'occasion de la préparation du rapport
présenté à la commission des lois sur
les polices municipales cette
proposition vient susciter des réformes
des avancées que nous avions suggéré
dans les recommandations émises aux
termes de ce rapport notre collègue rené
vandierendonck et - même le constat qui
les avaient précédées témoigne d'une
évolution profonde de la mission de la
police du maire
subissant à la fois une crise de
croissance et une crise d'identité
ces forces se différencient selon les
besoins des territoires les attentes de
nos concitoyens et les missions qui leur
sont confiées ce faisant notre rapport
ne porte pas sur la police municipale
mais s'attache à a examiné les polices
municipales la crise de croissance est
assez impressionnante puisque en 1981 4
la france comportaient
5600 agents municipaux affectés à cette
mission alors qu'elle en compte plus de
18000 aujourd'hui tous statuts confondus
la police des mers constitue un effectif
global de plus de 27 mille agents soit
plus de 10% des effectifs cumulés de la
police et de la gendarmerie nationale la
crise d'identité est engendrée par la
différence entre les missions exercées
et l'évolution de celle-ci en matière de
sécurité publique les responsabilités se
veulent clairement établie l'état en est
le garant sur l'ensemble du territoire
de la république le maire est chargé de
la police municipale qui selon l'article
2212 2 du code général des collectivités
territoriales a pour objet d'assurer le
bon ordre la sécurité la sûreté et la
salubrité publique sur le terrain
cependant les compétences apparaissent
plus floues les dérives découlant d'un
certain désengagement des forces
régaliennes les effectifs se sont
affaiblies au cours des dernières années
les implantations territoriales ont
diminué de ce fait les maires doivent
bien souvent pallier le retrait de
l'état en étoffant leur service de
police municipale le paysage se révèle
aujourd'hui confus les rôles respectifs
des uns des autres brouiller des
questions se posent quant au statut des
personnels au mode opératoire à la
coopération entre les différents
intervenants enfin à l'augmentation
progressive des pouvoirs judiciaires des
polices municipales
l'ensemble de ces considérations conduit
donc à s'interroger sur l' équilibre
général des dispositions législatives
réglementaires en vigueur c'est pourquoi
avec mon collègue rené vandierendonck
après avoir procédé à un état des lieux
des polices municipales de leur cadre
juridique nous proposons quelques
évolutions
certes le cadre général des missions de
toutes les polices municipales est posée
par les différentes lois dans celle du
15 avril
1990 9 qui a étendu les missions les
compétences des agents puis celle de
2007 et 2011 pour autant il existe une
grande diversité des pratiques sur le
terrain la physionomie de chaque police
municipale dépendant essentiellement des
décisions prises par le maire
qu'y at il en effet de commun entre la
petite police municipale doté de
quelques agents et la police dotée de
très nombreux agents d'un système de
vidéosurveillance et d'un centre de
supervision urbain
traditionnellement la police municipale
doit d'abord assurer la mise en oeuvre
des pouvoirs de police administrative du
maire essentiellement tournées vers la
prévention des troubles à l'ordre public
à seules fins d'assurer la préservation
du bien vivre ensemble
il s'agit donc de régler des conflits
sociaux par la médiation la persuasion
la dissuasion en s'appuyant sur le sens
civique des citoyens
une pratique qui domine d'ailleurs
encore dans de nombreuses communes en
particulier les plus petites les gardes
champêtres dans les effectifs ont connu
une érosion massive depuis un siècle
exerce des compétences souvent proche de
celle des policiers municipaux bien que
davantage orientée sur les problèmes
ruraux il est à souligner que le rôle
qu'il joue dans le domaine
environnemental
protection du patrimoine naturel police
de l'eau des réserves naturelles et
réglementations al de l'accès la nature
ira croissant si l'activité
traditionnelle de la police municipale
est ainsi à dominante préventive les
règles du bien vivre un split implique
pardon une part de répression sous forme
de contravention prévue par la loi ou
par des arrêtés municipaux les agents de
police municipale verbalise ainsi
principalement les contraventions aux
arrêtés de police du maire au code de la
route et les infractions un certain
nombre d'arrêtés pris en vertu de
pouvoirs de police spéciale la diversité
des compétences de la police municipale
posent la question de l'unité du corps
chargé d'assumer la diversité de ses
missions il est en effet possible de
verbaliser des infractions aussi vaste
et aussi différentes que celles que l'on
trouve dans le code de la santé publique
autant qu'au code rural qu'au code de la
voirie pur routière et à celui des
débits de boisson et au code de
l'urbanisme force est de reconnaître que
nous assistons depuis plusieurs années à
un élargissement et un certain
durcissement de la notion de
tranquillité publique tranquillité
publique est également une notion
expressément mentionnée dans l'article
2212 2 du code des collectivités
territoriales quelles que soient leurs
tendances politiques
il est de plus en plus fréquent que les
maires développe une politique
comportant une dose de réparation plus
forte dans le but de lutter d'une part
contre le sentiment d'insécurité
d'autre part de répondre aux
sollicitations d'administrer qui ne
tolèrent de moins en moins des
comportements incivils eux mêmes en
progression naguère considéré comme
quelque peu obsolète les pouvoirs de
police liée à la tranquillité publique
sont réactivés et renforcé avec de
nombreuses arrêtés municipaux dans le
domaine de la prévention de la
délinquance des mineurs ou de leur
protection je fais là allusion aux
arrêtés par exemple relatifs au
couvre-feu de à la lutte contre la
mendicité agressive ou le racolage
contre la consommation d'alcool sur la
voie publique
les rassemblements nocturnes la
circulation bruyante de véhicules à deux
roues voire même les sonneries de
cloches je pourrais vous donner si vous
le souhaitez quelques exemples
jurisprudentielle sur ce point
parallèlement à cette évolution les
polices municipales les plus importantes
en nombre d'agents et en extension de
leurs fonctions temps à mettre moins
l'accent sur les otages et à la présence
sur la voie publique pour devenir plus
réactives aux demandes des maires et des
citoyens la terre de tranquillité
publique l'exemple emblématique qui est
évidemment nice dont les agents au
nombre de 578 ont des missions si large
qu'elle se rapproche de celle des forces
nationales sont placées sous le signe de
la réactivité du professionnalisme et
sont dotés d'équipements extrêmement
moderne
le maire d'evry illustre également cette
évolution considérant même je le cite
mot-à-mot la police municipale est le
premier niveau de la sécurité pas de la
tranquillité comme le souligne la
sociologue virginie malo chez les
habitants évalue ainsi désormais la
qualité d'une police municipale autant
par sa capacité à répondre rapidement
aux demandes qu'à sa présence visible
sur le terrain au delà du renforcement
des actions de tranquillité publique les
missions des agents de police municipale
ont tendance à se rapprocher de celle
des forces nationales en se judiciarise
ans cette transformation compagne à
l'infléchissement des missions vers
davantage d'interventions de répression
et de travail judiciaire au sein de
certaines polices municipales l'accent
est ainsi mis de manière croissante sur
la verbaliser s'ils ont des flagrants
délits les interprétations suivi de mise
à disposition et de relations très
quotidienne avec la police ou la
gendarmerie nationale il s'agit avant
tout de faire appliquer les lois et de
combattre vigoureusement la délinquance
de voie publique en matière d'infraction
routière les policiers municipaux ont
progressivement acquis une palette très
large de prérogatives dans le cadre des
conventions de coordination
certaines polices municipales
interviennent fréquemment au soutien des
forces de sécurité nationales la
vidéosurveillance devenu un passage
quasi obligé pour une politique de
sécurité locales qui se veut dynamique
peut constituer un élément structurant
de la coopération entre ces deux corps
surtout dans les zones urbaines
connaissant un taux plus élevé de
délinquance enfin la communauté
autorisation des polices municipales et
menée au sein de communautés
d'agglomération et de communautés de
communes même si elle préserve le
pouvoir de police des mers le passage au
niveau intercommunal ainsi permis à
certaines communes rurales doté de peu
de ressources de bénéficier d'une
présence policière accrue la police
intercommunale qui ne peut guère alors
porter le nom plus à doses adaptées de
police territoriale permet d'assurer
ainsi la continuité de l'action de la
police municipale au delà des limites
géographiques de la commune voilà très
synthétiser le constat vous pourrez
retrouver toutes les informations
nécessaires sur l'état des lieux dans le
rapport d'information publié le 14
septembre 2012 tendant vers six
objectifs principaux 25 propositions
communes ont été formulées parvenir
gandhienne donc et moi même elles
contiennent des préconisations
pragmatique non partisane entrant dans
les espaces législatif et réglementaire
je salue à cet instant l'excellente
collaboration est la parfaite entente
qui nous a réunis auquel succède un
travail très ouvert avec les ministres
de l'intérieur monsieur manuel valls et
bernard cazeneuve toujours dans cet
esprit rené vente directe donc va
désormais vous présenter les axes de
notre proposition de loi sur l'ensemble
desquels notre accord est entier
merci monsieur pilet la parole est à
monsieur rené vandierendonck
que coauteur de la proposition de loi
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des lois madame la
rapporteure mes chers collègues
à l'occasion du débat sur les polices
municipales organisées en janvier 2013
dans cet hémicycle notre collègue eliane
assassi
avait appelé de ses voeux que les
travaux de cette mission d'information
ne reste pas dans les tiroirs que soit
enclenché une clarification du statut
social des policiers municipaux avec une
réflexion globale sur la police
municipale puisse s'engager le nous y
sommes employés avec françois pilé et ça
justifie le dépôt de cette proposition
de loi à la vérité nous avons eu
beaucoup de chance puisque non seulement
le ministre de l'intérieur de l'époque
étaient venus participer à ce débat mais
en plus c'est après le débat il a créé
les plus larges conditions pour qu'un
travail partenarial avec ses services
puissent se dérouler ainsi d'ailleurs
qu'avec les principales organisations
syndicales de policiers je veux ici
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur vous
qui avait continué dans cette voie vous
remercier personnellement remercier
aussi les directions générales du
ministère de l'intérieur je pense à la
dgcl mais aussi à la direction des
libertés publiques et des affaires
juridiques parce qu'un travail j'oublie
pas le presser blanche ou un travail
très considérable a été effectué ce qui
montre que vous avez entendu donner à
cette proposition de loi une véritable
portée c'était d'autant plus
à mettre à votre actif qu'une partie de
l'efficacité de ce dont nous allons
discuter
relève aussi du domaine réglementaire et
donc va nous permettre dans ce domaine
je l'espère et je l'appelle de mes voeux
de continuer à
participer à la concertation avec vos
services trois axes forts pour résumer
le contenu de la proposition de loi un
nouveau cadre d'emploi unifiée pour les
police territoriale
adossé à une formation renforcée
deuxième acte l'optimisation du
partenariat entre les forces armées de
l'état comme on dit elle et police
territoriale au travers
les conventions de coordination et un
troisième une troisième dimension mais
il faut dire que j'avais la chance de
travailler avec ma collègue traunsee
c'est effectivement la mutualisation
intercommunale sans venir toucher d'un
iota le pouvoir de police du maire alors
allant dans l'ordre un nouveau cadre
d'emploi unifiée pour les police
territoriale adossé à une formation
renforcée
on a beau dire que leur origine le
plonge dans le coeur du haut moyen-âge
landes le sang force est de constater
qu'il n'ya plus que mille quatre cents
gendarmes en france il nous a paru
important alors que dans le même temps
comme l'a dit une autre collègue piles
et on voyait les policiers municipaux
augmenté en nombre
de clarifier les missions des uns et des
autres d'autant plus que les agents de
surveillance de la voie publique asvp
était aussi apparu entre temps donc nous
avons eu l'ambition
et je salue madame la rapporteure parce
qu'elle a beaucoup insisté dans son
rapport sur ce point l'ambition à
l'éclair valoriser le métier de policier
territoriales si pelé verbe transitif
apporter ce qui
eh bien nous l'avons entendu reconnaître
leur mission et en faire des missions
complémentaires et non pas supplétifs de
la police nationale donc j'insiste là
dessus le premier volet vise à améliorer
la qualification
les conditions de travail l'avancement
des carrières monsieur le ministre vous
aurez l'occasion de dire déjà un certain
nombre d'étapes qui ont été franchies
depuis que le débat a eu lieu ici même
et bien sûr nous avons placé et madame
le rapporteur qui était très attaché
la formation au coeur de la proposition
d'évolution
législatives il s'agit d'ailleurs d'une
préoccupation qui était partagé par le
ministère et nous n'avons eu de cesse
cher françois piles et que vraiment de
mettre une amicale mais insistante
pression sur le centre national de la
fonction publique territoriale pour
obtenir ce qui est notre objectif
une grande
école nationale de formation des agents
de police municipale qui serait bien sûr
sous l'égide du centre national de
formation publique territoriale et qui
pourraient s'appuyer sur deux
regroupements un niveau interrégional
avec des formations spécialisées
répondant mieux à ce que tous les
personnels appellent de leurs voeux
c'est à dire des formations à la carte
au plus haut niveau de qualification et
de labellisation de leur catalogue de
propositions
donc sur ce point nous avons un point
encore en débat mais on est là pour ça
c'est que nous avons relayé ce que le
questionnaire des maires des quatre
mille mère faisait apparaître c'est à
dire ce que la mf
avait mis aussi au coeur de ses propres
demandes nous souhaitons que l'avis
préalable de fin de formation initiale
des livres est donc par le président du
cnfpt
et bien
permet donc préalablement d'éclairer
l'avis du préfet et du procureur sur la
capacité professionnelle de l'agent son
comportement ou encore les savoirs
techniques acquis pendant la formation
c'est à dire qu'on ne puisse pas avoir
d'agrément avant explicitement que
procureur et préfet et pu viser ledit
avis je souhaite bien sûr également
donné acte au ministre de l'intérieur
des avancées réalisées en matière d'ess
vp qui est parfois un pavillon de
complaisance c'est à dire des catégories
d'agents sur lesquels moi j'en vois
certains qui sont armés j'en vois
certains qui verbalisent donc été
important j'en vois qui sont dans la
vidéosurveillance
donc je pense qu'il est important que
ces agents
puissent avoir maintenant un cadre
d'emplois claire et la clarté elle se
justifie aussi par la formation et je
vous en donne acte monsieur le ministre
des avancées ont pu être réalisés
deuxième axe
je vais accélérer l'optimisation du
partenariat entre les forces de l'état
et les police territoriale à travers la
convention de coordination
donc il existe quatre mille police
municipale
2230 convention de coordination à décret
récent leur a donné un peu plus de
contenu mais dans
statistiquement dans la pratique ces
conventions de coordination sont trop
souvent formelle est déséquilibré peu
d'entre elles se basent sur un
diagnostic
contextualiser de la sécurité sur le
territoire concerné en lien avec le
conseil local de sécurité et de
prévention de la délinquance
leur contenu
ne se traduit pas toujours une dynamique
de partenariat entre les forces
étatiques et les forces locales mais
peut parfois faire penser à une
subordination des agents municipaux
enfin le suivi de ces conventions est
largement à parfaire donc tout notre
travail a consisté sur ce point à
dynamiser et à rééquilibrer
contractuellement ces conventions de
coordination afin qu'il soit le lieu de
la co élaboration de la coproduction de
du suivi de la relation pro du co
production de sécurité sur un territoire
là aussi mes chers collègues nous avons
encore un point en discussion c'est que
nous souhaitons à puisque tous les
maires sont d'accord le judiciaire point
trop n'en faut on s'en tient là mais au
moins quand on exerce des compétences
judiciaires qu'on ait les moyens de
l'exercer
donc voilà pourquoi nous avons obtenu là
aussi à en accord avec la ms nous tenons
à ce que le procureur de la république
puisse pour ce qui le concerne être co
signataire desdites conventions et c'est
un point qui sera bien sûr dans le débat
également
donc dernière idée pour aller plus vite
la mutualisation à l'échelle
intercommunale
madame escoffier nous avons tenu en dans
des temps récents
à montrer vous souvenez le débat ici sur
la loi
ma femme a montré que
on pouvait concilier pouvoirs de police
du maire
et intercommunales isation de certaines
fonctions support en jouant sur la
fameuse mutualisation ascendante nous
avons montré dans le débat
que celle ci n'était pas du rêve mais
qu'elle existait alors pour ceux qui
n'ont jamais entendu parler du haut-rhin
patienter quelques instants je voudrais
donc pour ne pas déflorer ce sujet dire
que si je questionnais mon collègue
pileje une des choses les plus
intéressantes que l'on ait vu
fonctionner
c'est précisément
le système en place dans la communauté
d'agglomération du val de morency cavam
est d'ailleurs celle de roissy porte de
france puisque là nous avons rencontré
tous les maires et nous ont tous dit que
sur leur territoire de leur commune ils
n'avaient pas perdu une once de leurs
prérogatives et pourtant ils nous ont
dit nous avons pu en intercommunalité
ans les fonctions supports progresser
considérablement puisque un stick un
système de transmission informatique de
données anonymisées validé par la cnil
existe comme existe d'ailleurs une prise
en charge à l'échelle intercommunale de
toutes les fonctions support et
notamment du fonctionnement du fameux
csu et vous savez en nous quittant la
sur le pas de la porte et françois pinet
le président nous disais ah oui j'ai
oublié de vous dire ça avait un autre
avantage c'est qu'avant qu'on fasse ça
il y avait un turnover hausse à la
police municipale de 30% qui est tombée
aujourd'hui à 13% donc en conclusion
nous souhaitons continuer à travailler
ensemble sur cette question qui est au
coeur des préoccupations des maires avec
le permis de construire le dirai à deux
puisque on a eu récemment un débat sur
les la question et je voudrais dire
m'adressant à l'ensemble des agents et
policiers municipaux et d'arte champêtre
qui concourent à la prévention de la
délinquance et à sa répression dans un
certain nombre de cas que le sénat bien
au delà des clivages n'a eu de cesse que
de rechercher à reconnaître leur
profession et à valoriser leur carrière
merci la parole est à madame virginie
klès rapporteur de la commission des
lois
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues et mes
chers collègues co auteurs de cette
proposition de loi à mon tour de vous
dire à quel point j'ai été à la fois
passionné est satisfaite et à quel point
c'était facile que de prendre ce travail
un petit peu en marche finalement après
les nombreux rapports les nombreuses
personnalités qui se sont penchés sur ce
berceau de la création d'une police
territoriale aussi bien notre collègue
le cers il fut un temps avec un rapport
d'information sur le maire et la
prévention de la délinquance que les
deux co auteurs précités rené
vandierendonck et françois pillet deux
ministres de l'intérieur qui se sont
succédé aussi sur le sujet avec
exactement le même discours est le même
engagement auprès de cette proposition
de loi est encore le groupe de travail
autour du préfet blanche ou en
coordination et en concertation avec
l'ensemble des forces vives autour du
sujet encore donc un consensus qui
n'exclut pas le débat ou bien au
contraire mais un débat constructif un
vrai débat de partenariat et de co
construction de coproduction législative
vous ne m'empêcherez pas pour autant
d'adressés un petit signe amical et un
petit signe venant du fond du coeur au
gardes-champêtres moi qui suis plutôt
sénatrice des campagnes que sénatrice
des villes c'est vrai que ce nom de
garde champêtre fleurait bon la campagne
que quelles que soient les positions
prises par les uns ou par les autres
aujourd'hui il va disparaître du
vocabulaire usuel pour autant leur
mission leur métier lui ne va pas
disparaître mission ne va plus les
appeler gardes-champêtres demain cette
proposition de loi cette création des
polices territoriales
pardonnez-moi si j'utilise encore des
termes un peu scientifique mais les
termes scientifiques ont ceci
d'avantageux c'est que comme les textes
comme les mots juridique pendant ils ont
un sens très précis donc il s'agit pas
là de phagocytose c'est à dire qu'il
n'ya pas une police municipale qui mange
qui digère et qui réduit en élément est
un élément unitaire l'épauler garde
champêtre il ya bien conjugaison c'est à
dire finalement l'addition de deux
forces addition de deux compétences
l'addition de deux métiers pour en
former un nouvel pour former un nouvel
organisme pour former les police
territoriale et monsieur le ministre
voilà une des raisons pour lesquelles
nous tenons à ce nom à cette appellation
de police territoriale oui je sais bien
c'est un point de désaccord mais c'est
important pour nous que de marquer aussi
par le nom que ce ne sont pas les
polices municipales qui une fois plus
faible au site les guerres de champêtre
mais que ce sont bien ses biens la
création d'une nouvelle force de police
locale que seront les police
territoriale talent en tout cas que les
normes pour l'instant la commission la
commission des lois
police territoriale avec donc bien les
compétences des gardes champêtres et des
policiers municipaux d'hier on travaille
bien en l'occurrence à droit constant
alors parmi les arguments parce que la
commission elle-même a débattu du nom et
dans et en tant que rapporteur de la
commission je me dois de vous rapporter
l'ensemble ces débats parmi les éléments
qui nous ont semblé important et qui
aurait milité en faveur d'un retour ou
de rester au terme de police municipale
l'argument du coup il est vrai que ça
nul lui est indifférent le coup de hrw
look et le coup de resigner lisez le
coup de changer les les insignes et
cetera est effectivement un élément
important mais sur lequel aujourd'hui
nous n'avons pas réellement de chiffrage
ou en tout cas nous n'avons pas
réellement de données précises et
objectives sur le sujet donc nous en
sommes restés à la police territoriale
en l'état actuel des choses
le volet important qui a fait consensus
ou plus ou moins consensus cette fois ci
et le volet de la formation messad cela
des gets excellemment dit par mon
collègue van dieren donc la formation
qui resteraient du ressort du cnfpt b
lequel s'est déjà engagée sur à la fois
une réflexion autour de l'inter
régionalisation de ces formations sur un
effectué autour de l'homogénéisation et
de la labellisation de ces formateurs
parce que c'est vrai et je les dis aussi
en son temps le niveau des formations le
degré de satisfaction des maires par
rapport aux formations dispensées par le
cnfpt n'était pas le même sur toute la
france ou de même selon les modules
un point auquel la commission des lois
tient essentiellement est effectivement
or des vents dirais donc là dit aussi la
transmission de l'attestation de fin de
formation initiale par le président du
cnfpt au préfet et au procureur avant le
prononcé de l'agrément à cela il ya
plusieurs raisons souvent on pense que
la transmission de cette attestation de
fin de formation pourrait induire de
façon systématique un effet négatif sur
la
l'autorisation sur l'agrément qui serait
dit c'est à dire que on regarderait dans
cette attestation de fin de formation si
vraiment on peut pas trouver des
éléments qui font que la personne en
question n'a pas les capacités à devenir
policier municipal et que donc on ne
donnerait pas l'agrément la personne en
question
mais la situation inverse peut aussi se
produire c'est pour ça que nous tenons
vraiment à ce que préfet procureur et
l'ensemble des éléments à disposition
sachant que tout ce qui relève de la
formation initiale n'est pas de ne
seraient pas des éléments liant mais des
éléments qui peuvent éclairer son
jugement et qui peuvent éclairer sa
décision en matière d'agrément tout
simplement parce que certaines personnes
peuvent avoir fait un certain nombre de
bêtises certains moments de leur vie et
que leur comportement pendant la
formation leur comportement depuis le
jour où ils ont fait des bêtises va au
contraire plaidé en faveur de ce n'était
que des bêtises de jeunesse et oui cette
personne aujourd'hui a bel et bien les
capacités pour être policier municipal
j'ai vécu ce type d'exemple dans ma
commune où effectivement j'ai recruté
des personnes qui n'avaient pas
forcément un casier judiciaire
complètement vierge aujourd'hui les
casiers judiciaires seront plus assez
vite de tout un tas de choses diverses
et variées et qui en fait après ses
erreurs de jeunesse commises à 18 ans
avait complètement démontré par la suite
qu'elles avaient toutes les capacités
requises en l'occurrence pour s'occuper
de jeunes et de prévention de la
délinquance donc je pense que c'est
vraiment fondamental que de disposer
avant de donner de délivrer avait
vraiment aussi important que celui de
policier territoria c'est un fondamental
de disposer de l'ensemble des éléments
dont on peut disposer
en lot en l'occurrence d'autant qu' il
ne faut pas oublier que le retrait de
l'agrément éventuel sera également
soumis au préfet au procureur et que la
décision de retrait d'agrément ou de non
délivrance de l'agrément lit le maire
autorités territoriales en matière
d'affectation et en matière de
titularisation des agents de police
territoriale
en matière de formation nous avons tenu
aussi à ce que les asvp les agents de
sécurité de la voie publique mais aussi
les assistants temporaire de la police
municipale fasse l'objet d'une formation
bien évidemment adapté leur mission suit
un amendement de nos collègues du rds
aussi qu'on avait tout à l'heure en
commission sans doute avec un
aménagement dans le temps pour leur
permettre de prendre leurs fonctions
malgré tout dans des délais assez courts
mais ces agents de sécurité la voie
publique comme les assistants port à la
police municipale sont sur la voie
publique sont dans une tenue uniforme
donc doivent bénéficier d'un minimum de
formation tant pour les mettre en
sécurité eux que pour mettre les
communes pour lesquelles ils agissent
les collectivités pour lesquelles ils
agissent en sécurité juridique
l'intercommunalité nous semble
incontournable il faut aller vers plus
de l'intercommunalité il faut aller vers
plus de mutuelle et de mutualisation
donc un certain nombre de mesures aussi
de cette proposition de loi vont
favoriser l'intercommunalité pour autant
malgré les propositions initiales nous
n'avons pas accepté en commission des
lois de donner la compétence officier de
police judiciaire au président d opci
tout simplement parce que c'est déjà une
fonction tellement peu utilisé par les
maires qu'on ne voit pas très bien à
quel moment où quelle occasion pour l
utiliser les présidents de pci et parce
qu'on voit bien l'élargissement qui
seraient demandés demain au
vice-président aussi des opci donc
pourquoi démultipliée l'attribution de
cette fonction dopé j à des personnes
qui ne l'utiliserai pas ça ne nous
sommes là par contre pas aller dans le
bon sens en revanche en revanche
transférer les pouvoirs de police
spéciale au président d opci de manière
à leur permettre d'exercer complètement
les compétences qui leur ont été
transférées nous a paru une bonne chose
et afin de faciliter supprimer aussi la
superposition
des comités locaux de sécurité de
prévention de la délinquance avec les
comités intercommunaux de sécurité et de
prévention de la délinquance je vois que
certains d'entre vous offre la tête et
ne sont pas convaincus je vais essayer
de vous convaincre mon cher collègue
j'ai aussi de vous convaincre pourquoi
suppression des deux parce que un comité
local de sécurité prévention délinquance
est une instance très fort mais les
traits formalisé qui doit être présidé
par un certain nombre de personnes dont
les fonctions sont clairement définis si
ça se superposent avec un comité inter
enfin conseil intercommunal de sécurité
et de prévention de délinquance les
mêmes personnes ne présideront jamais
les deux sessions ont tous les trois
quatre ou cinq sessions même si elle
avait besoin et de fait ce serait des
espèces de grandes messes qui ne
fonctionnerait sans doute pas bien ou
sans doute de façon bancale moi je pense
qu'il vaut mieux un comité un seul
conseil intercommunal de sécurité prend
sur la délinquance qui sur un territoire
correctement raisonnée va répartir à la
fois l'organisation des moyens la
répartition des moyens va se renseigner
sur l'évolution de la délinquance il sa
géographie ou le changement de nature de
la délinquance et va confier ensuite à
des commissions infra
territoriale par rapport à ce conseil
intercommunal s'il est probant si c'est
vraiment une trop grande messe et ce
sont ces petits groupes de travail infra
conseil intercommunal de sécurité
pourront s'en aller intense qui feront
le travail effectif qui feront le
travail opérationnel sans forcément être
présidée par le président de pci par le
procureur ou par le préfet et ce niveau
de relations et de travail et celui qui
est efficace avec un retour vers le
conseil intercommunal pour de temps en
temps faire le point et voir où est ce
qu'on a poussé la délinquance quand on
l'a poussé dans un certain sens
géographique de nature donc c'est
vraiment l'organisation je suis tout à
fait d'accord avec ceux qui disent que
l'intercommunalité le pc n'est pas
forcément l'échelon d'action efficace
mais je pense que c'est l'échelon
d'organisation et de répartition des
moyens et de transmission de
l'information générale qui est
effectivement efficace donc voilà une
des raisons fondamentales pour
lesquelles nous ne souhaitons pas que
les deux se superposent les conventions
de coordination c'est à dire les
rapports entre l'état et les
collectivités territoriales nous sommes
primordial et la commission est allé
plus loin encore que le souhaitez
nateur pierre- andy rain donc en allant
vraiment vers une réciprocité et vers
une égalité de pouvoir de décision en la
matière chaque fois que c'était possible
et juste que jusqu'au bac simone des
possibilités nous souhaitons aussi que
ces conventions de coordination se
généralise pour autant nous ne
souhaitons pas non plus bousculés les
plus petites communes rurales qui
n'avait qu'un seul gardes-champêtres
hier et qui demain vont avoir un
policier territoriale et risquerait
demain naître en plus obligés de
repasser une convention de coordination
alors que leur territoire rural ne
nécessite pas de travail de nuit ne
nécessite pas d'armement et c'était et
c'est donc tous sont les communes ou les
intercommunalités à aller vers ces
conventions de coordination
mais n'allons pas trop vite laissons
leur le temps de souffler de respirer et
d'en avoir besoin et surtout d'avoir
besoin d'utiliser leurs policiers
territoriale au maximum de tout ce qu'il
peut faire autrement dit les conventions
de coordination seront de toute façon
obligatoire tels que nous vous le
proposons en tout cas à partir du moment
où les agents de police territoriale
devrait travailler de nuit devraient
être armées
hulu devrait faire des
actions avec la police nationale ou avec
la gendarmerie nationale donc incitons
fortement des collectivités à y aller
mais alors doucement avant de les rendre
obligatoires
quelques mesures supplémentaires bien
évidemment concernant les fichiers accès
au fichier direct dans certains cas oui
chaque fois que l'accès aux fichiers et
rendu indispensable pour l'exercice des
seules attributions des policiers
territoriaux et non pas pour le reste
donc avoir accès que aux informations
qui leur sont indispensables pour
l'exercice de leurs missions c'est en
tout cas aujourd'hui la position de la
commission des lois et dans les
conventions de coordination prévoyons
aussi un petit peu mieux les modalités
de transmission des informations il
arrive que les forces d'état soit un
petit peu réticente à transmettre les
informations parce que c'est un petit
peu aussi leur pré carré c'est humain
c'est légitime mais justement pouces on
l'est à aller vers plus de coordination
vers plus de réel partenariat et non pas
à rendre les un supplétif des autres ou
les un subordonné des autres en matière
de centre de surveillance urbain urbaine
pardon
là encore des nécessités de formation
des opérateurs essentiellement c'est ce
que nous vous proposons
je ne vous parlerai pas non plus des
brigades vertes delà de la moselle je
serai notre collègue catherine tremblay
qui connaît sa sur le bout des doigts et
dont je sais qu'elle est très très
attaché à ces brigades vertes vous de
vous en parler sur le volet social ça ne
relève pas du de la loi ça prenait du
réglementaire néanmoins monsieur le
ministre quelques réflexions que nous
avons entendu et pour lesquels nous
sommes important d'avoir sans doute
votre avis où votre opposition
en matière alors là c'est pas sur le
volet social lui-même c'est sur le volet
réglementaire en matière de tenue
aujourd'hui les textes prévoient que les
tenues des uns et des autres doivent
permettre de les distinguer parfaitement
les humbles les uns des autres
police municipale de la police nationale
les asvp doivent se distinguer des
policiers municipaux et les assistants
temporaire de police municipale doivent
être distingués des polices municipales
de fait de très bons nombreux
témoignages concordent y compris celui
de votre humble serviteur les uniformes
se ressemblent les voitures se ressemble
peut-être ce texte est il l'occasion les
décrets qui vont suivre sont-ils
d'occasions de revoir un petit peu ce
sujet deux points sur lesquels je n'ai
pas de solution la commission n'a pas de
solution mais pense pour autant que les
remarques qu'elle a entendu de la part
de certains syndicats se sont tassées
justifier un premier concerne les
détachements les détachements des
policiers nationaux ou des gendarmes
vers la police municipale qui quand ils
se font se font quasi exclusivement sur
les postes d'encadrement qui sont déjà
peu nombreux pour les policiers
territoriaux et qui de fait laisse un
sentiment d'injustice et d'amertume au
policier territoriaux qui ne voit plus
que très très peu de postes
d'encadrement pouvoir leur être leur
être offert et un deuxième sujet qui
nous a semblé aussi important en
commission qui est le contingentement de
certains indices en matière de carrière
des policiers territoriaux à des tailles
de collectivités de 10000 habitants
autant le congé le contingentement et la
nécessité d'exercer des responsabilités
pour atteindre ces ordis nous semble
normal et naturel autant nous pensons
qu'ils ne sont pas forcément liés à la
taille de la commune et qui ferait
peut-être mieux les et l'exercice
effectif de responsabilités sous
l'autorité du maire qui est leur
employeur ou éventuellement à une taille
de brigades de police municipale mais
pas la taille de la ville dix mille
habitants certaines communes de 10000
habitants peuvent n'avoir que deux ou
trois policiers municipaux voire pas du
tout et des communes de cinq six mille
habitants avoir une vraie brigade de
policiers municipaux qui exercent
absolument toutes les fonctions et
toutes les missions des policiers
municipaux
voilà pour ce qui était des questions
qui ne relèvent sans doute pas dû de la
loi mais que la commission des lois faso
lesquels la commission des lois
souhaitait appeler votre attention
monsieur le monsieur le ministre et puis
pour le reste on aura l'occasion article
par article éventuellement de revenir et
compris sur les amendements 90 nous
étant parvenu tout à l'heure vous
comprendrez que je n'ai pas encore eu le
temps d'en faire une synthèse précise
est parfaite donc on y reviendra en
cours de débat en tout état de cause la
commission des lois a dans un très large
consensus une fois plus émis un avis
très favorable que le trait n'existe pas
en commission des lois un avis favorable
à cette proposition de moi je vous
remercie
merci madame la parole est à monsieur
bernard cazeneuve ministre de
l'intérieur
il ya un monsieur le président monsieur
le président de la commission des lois
messieurs les auteurs madame le
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs je suis particulièrement
heureux d'être parmi vous aujourd'hui
c'est la première fois qu'en tant que
ministre de l'intérieur je suis au banc
pour l'examen d'un texte législatif
et je voudrais en préambule salué le
travail très remarquable des sénateurs
menées dans un esprit républicain dont
nous sommes très nombreux ici à
souhaiter y servent de modèle pour
d'autres travaux tu a notamment salué
relève andy rain d'ong et françois pilée
mais également la rapporteure virginie
klès pour leur implication dans
l'élaboration de ce texte qui a fait
l'objet d'un travail ancien puisque le
rapport d'information intitulée de la
police municipale à la police
territoriale mieux assurer la
tranquillité publique et qui a été
répandu en octobre de l'année 2012 a
nourri cette proposition de loi dont
nous débattons aujourd'hui mon
prédécesseur avait déjà engagé avec vous
sur ce texte et ses propositions un
dialogue très fructueux que j'ai
naturellement poursuivi dès mon arrivée
au ministère de l'intérieur les services
du ministère en particulier la dlp agi
la dgcl la délégation en coopération de
sécurité ont contribué très utile mange
le crois a
entouré le texte de garanties juridiques
et techniques qui nous permettent
aujourd'hui de nous féliciter d'une
proposition de réforme cohérente et
complète
votre proposition de loi avait été au
coeur des échanges de la précédente ccpm
commission consultative des polices
municipales et je sais que vous attendez
avec impatience la prochaine réunion de
cette commission je vais vous annoncer
aujourd'hui qu'elle sera convoqué avant
l'été
votre ambition paraissait simple et je
veux dire qu'elle relever du bon sens
créer un cadre d'emplois unique par la
fusion des quatre de police municipale
et des gardes champêtres sur le plan du
droit pourtant la tâche a été beaucoup
plus compliquée qu'on avait pu
l'imaginer ainsi fallait qu'il préserver
des attributions spécifiques et les
prérogatives des gardes champêtres tout
en permettant l'exercice de toutes les
missions par l'ensemble des agents du
nouveau cadre d'emploi les agents du
cadre d'emplois ainsi fusionner devront
donc bénéficier d'une formation
identique d'une durée de six mois
actuellement la formation initiale des
agents de police municipale dure six
mois et celle des gardes champêtres
n'est que de trois mois
la fusion des deux cadres d'emplois
permettra donc aux gardes champêtres
bénéficier de dispositions plus
favorables
pour leur carrière je pense notamment à
l'avancement au 3ème grade possible
après six années au lieu de 11 années
actuellement la possibilité de
bénéficier à terme du futur échelons
spéciale de fin de catégorie c mais je
pense aussi à l'accès à la catégorie b
qui deviendra désormais possible en
outre le taux de l'indemnité spécifique
de fonction passera de 16 à
20% maximum ce qui n'est pas non plus
totalement négligeable
d après promulgation de la loi et
consultation des organisations
syndicales et les représentants des
employeurs territoriaux les dispositions
réglementaires sur les quais les
services ont déjà travaillé pourront
être publiés la fusion devenir effective
vous avez également souhaité et je m'en
félicite à ce que l'ensemble des agents
qui concourt à l'exercice des missions
de police municipale trouve dans cette
loi la reconnaissance de la place qu'ils
occupent
le projet de texte permet la
clarification du rôle et des missions
des agents de surveillance de la voie
publique
fort de plus de six mille cinq cents
agents en 2013
la rapporteur a eu le souci de renforcer
leur statut par une disposition
législative qui prévoit l'acquisition
d'une formation préalable est prêt
parent à l'exercice de fonctions d'agent
de police judiciaire sur la voie
publique cette formation devrait être
assurée par le centre national de la
fonction publique territoriale qui
dispose comme vous le savez d'un
monopole en la matière le décret
d'application définira donc les
modalités le contenu et la durée il
réglera également la teneur des
équipements attachés à la fonction tels
que la carte professionnelle a tenu les
véhicules utilisable
cette proposition de loi doit permettre
la reconnaissance du rôle des agents qui
apportent leur contribution à la mise en
oeuvre de la sécurité publique locale
ainsi et nous irons viendront j'en suis
certain au cours du débat elle pourrait
être un vecteur utile pour reconnaître
la fonction des centres de supervision
urbaine qui apporte un soutien précieux
aux policiers municipaux dans leurs
tâches quotidiennes en 2013 environ
quatre centres de supervision urbaine
communaux et intercommunaux était en
fonction sur le territoire national leur
déploiement doit être encouragée ainsi
que le raccordement aux salles de
commandement des forces de sécurité de
l'état pour permettre le dépôt d'image
en cas notamment d' événement grave de
sécurité publique d'ordre public ou de
sécurité civile pour avoir effectué
plusieurs déplacements sur ces
thématiques en province y compris dans
de grandes villes je pense notamment à
la ville de marseille j'ai pu mesurer à
quel point ces outils sont des outils
utiles
non pas qu'ils se substituent à la
police nationale la gendarmerie
nationale mais ils sont un élément
d'élucidation de faits qui sont
constatés apportent un concours très
précieux aux forces de police et de
gendarmerie dans l'exercice que ces
forces font
de l'élucidation des faits délictueux
commis
il faut également saisir
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
l'opportunité de cette ppl pour exiger
des opérateurs le professionnalisme qui
s'impose aux acteurs d'une tâche aussi
stratégique c'est ainsi qu'il est
proposé que l'exercice de ces missions
soient subordonnées à l'accomplissement
l'accomplissement pendant une formation
préalable
ce à quoi bien entendu le gouvernement
est absolument favorables la proposition
de loi dans la mesure où elle entend à
travers les conventions de coordination
renforcée rénover les relations entre
polices municipales et forces de
sécurité nationale contribue également à
l'émergence de nouvelles formes de
coopération sur le terrain entre les
différents acteurs de la sécurité ce qui
est également une excellente chose cette
coproduction de la sécurité j'en suis
totalement convaincu est un concept qui
doit structurer notre approche de la
sécurité dans les territoires et je
place cette occupation au coeur de mon
action au ministère de l'intérieur
l'expérience prouve que la signature
d'une convention de coordination à
condition bien sûr qu'on lui donne vie
et qu'on en assure a suivi attentif et
l'homme est le meilleur moyen de
parvenir à une complémentarité efficace
des forces de sécurité c'est là l'un des
piliers de la lutte contre l'insécurité
la rapporteur a d'ailleurs souhaité a
baissé à 4 agents le seuil au delà
duquel une convention de coordination
est obligatoire je m'en réjouis bien
entendu car nous savons tous que c'est
un outil pour le maire qui peut y
préciser les missions qu'il entend
confier à sa police municipale
décliné également la doctrine d'emploi
de cette police pour mieux centrer son
action sur son coeur de métier la
tranquillité publique le ministère de
l'intérieur veillera à faciliter la
tâche des petites communes qui
souhaiteront signer ces conventions en
faisant l'abhorré par ses services des
conventions types tenant compte des
caractéristiques locales
qu'il s'agisse des stations balnéaires
de villages de montagne où de plus
ruraux je pense que la préparation de
ces conventions types pour être un autre
utile aux maires des collectivités
concernées non pas que cet outil à
vocation à les enfermer dans des normes
trop contraignantes qui ne
correspondrait pas à la spécificité de
leur territoire mais au contraire ils
peuvent ces outils c'est peuvent ces
conventions qui constitue un cadre
facilement adaptable et de nature par
conséquent à permettre aux mères
d'élaborer facilement des textes
conventionnels qu'il souhaite mettre en
oeuvre en revanche je l' ai déjà dit au
à la rapporteure et ou aux auteurs de la
ppl je suis très réservé mais très
réservé sur la proposition de faire
signer le projet de convention de
coordination par le procureur de la
république je lui préfère le dispositif
de transmission
actuellement en vigueur du projet de
convention pour avis pour des raisons
que je veux expliquer d'abord parce que
ce dispositif sauvegarde une flexibilité
de la procédure d'élaboration et surtout
ménage un principe qui est très
important pour les juges comme pour les
acteurs publics et administratives qui
est le principe de séparation des
autorités administratives et judiciaires
il est souhaitable cependant de prévoir
la mise en place d'une instance de
pilotage qui elle pourrait associer le
maire le préfet et le procureur une fois
la convention de coordination signé mon
interrogation n'est donc pas une
interrogation destiné à laisser de côté
un acteur dont on a grandement besoin
qui est le procureur de la république
pour avoir été moi même mère je me
souviens au sein des groupes locaux de
traitement de la délinquance mais aussi
en raison de la convention police
municipale police nationale que nous
avions signé d'avoir toujours veillé à
l'association étroite des procureurs de
la république à nos démarches mais je
pense que pour le confort des procureurs
de la république comme des mères il faut
que l'association des procureurs aux
dispositifs de pilotage n'aille pas
jusqu'à l'agrément la signature de la
convention par eux pour les raisons que
je viens d'indiquer je veux également
précisé que si les conventions supposé
engagements réciproques de la part des
signataires
il est en revanche pas possible que la
police et la gendarmerie nationale
précise la nature et les lieux de leur
intervention en effet l'organisation des
forces de sécurité intérieure qui ont
vocation à intervenir sur tout le
territoire qu'elles courent ne permet
pas de répondre à cette demande en outre
comme vous le savez pour ceux d'entre
vous qui avez des responsabilités
locales l'assiette territoriale d'un
commissariat de police ou plus encore
d'unité territoriale de la gendarmerie
se compose de plusieurs communes ce qui
rend la mise en oeuvre de ce dispositif
complexe
cette organisation ne permet donc pas un
engagement contractualiser sur une seule
commune car le service doit être adaptée
dans le temps et l'espace en fonction de
l'analyse d'une situation à un moment
donné je veux dire aux sénateurs et
sénatrices qui ont souhaité cette
disposition que ma préoccupation en vous
mettant en garde c'est de faire en sorte
que les territoires garde des forces de
sécurité extraordinairement efficace en
leur permettant de se déployer là où
sont les urgences à tout moment sans que
l'évocation de cette convention qui n'a
encore une fois qu'un périmètre
municipal puisse venir
contrarier la relation entre les maires
et les préfets et maires pouvant se
réclamer du texte de la convention pour
regretter que les gendarmes ne soit pas
là au moment où il l'aurait souhaité et
les préfets pouvant justifier de
l'urgence qui apparaît en tel ou tel
point du territoire ou de priorités en
tel ou tel point du territoire pour
expliquer l'affectation un moment donné
deux gendarmes ou de policiers en tel ou
tel point
ce ne sont pas davantage des conventions
de coordination qui doivent préciser les
modalités d'accès des agents de police
municipale au traitement de données
personnelles
ces modalités sont approuvées par décret
ou arrêtés après avis de la commission
nationale informatique et libertés mais
je veux ici précisé qu'un travail
important a été entreprise sur ce point
par le comité de pilotage chargé du
dossier des polices municipales au sein
du ministère de l'intérieur
ce travail sera complété par celui
d'avant de réflexion émanation de la
commission consultative des polices
municipales s'il s'agit ici en effet de
préciser les conditions juridiques et
techniques dans lesquelles les policiers
municipaux pourraient obtenir le cas
échéant à l'accès direct à certains
fichiers en vue d'obtenir des
informations utiles à l'exercice de
leurs missions il s'agit de concevoir
des procédures d'authentification
de l'appelant de définir le spectre des
informations accessibles et de veiller à
l'exercice d'un réel contrôle de
l'officier de police judiciaire
tel que cela est exigé par le conseil
constitutionnel
je sais que nous aurons à débattre plus
précisément au cours de l'après-midi de
ces sujets mais je tenais néanmois à
dire deux mots
de mon attachement la dénomination
actuelle de police municipale
il est toujours bon qu'au sénat il y ait
un moment ou un autre des débats un
temps de réflexion sur l'épaisseur et la
signification sémantique est la charge
symbolique que revêt l'appellation ne
doit pas être négligé je ne crois pas
les polices municipales bénéficier en
terme d'image de cet attachement de nos
concitoyens à l'échelon local et à
l'institution municipale par ailleurs
des policiers municipaux ne sont pas
compétents sur un territoire mais ben
ali bien sûr le ressort d'une ou
plusieurs communes peuvent en tous les
cas lettre j'ajoute de même et vous
savez combien je suis sensible de par
mes anciennes fonctions à ce sujet à
cette question que le changement
d'appellation n'est pas neutre
financièrement
pas un petit sujet dans le contexte dans
lequel nous nous trouvons j'ai
d'ailleurs procédé moi même me laissant
aller à mon ancienne nature
des petits calculs et comme vous savez
après 50 ans la nature des êtres ne
change pas
donc j'ai fait un calcul et selon une
première approche le coup le coût de
cette appellation de ce changement
d'appellation serait de plus de 15
millions d'euros
ce paramètre a d'ailleurs suscité je
crois des réserves y compris au sein de
l'association des maires de france
al'inverse il peut s'avérer intéressant
de marquer le mouvement progressif et à
terme incontournables en direction d'une
mutualisation
intercommunale plus affirmée ça je peux
le comprendre je pense que pour les
mêmes raisons budgétaires cela peut
s'avérer souhaitable de telle
mutualisation tout ans opérant dans le
respect des pouvoirs de police du maire
peuvent permettre des économies
d'échelle et de structures qui sont
incontestables elles garantissent
également une action de police
municipale mieux adapté aux variations
dans l'espace et dans le temps des
besoins de présence et d'intervention là
où les polices municipales interviennent
sur un périmètre plus large ne faut-il
pas permettre sans forcément imposer de
changements au niveau national que leur
appellation fasse également référence à
leur territoire d'exercice au territoire
de l'intercommunalité par exemple cette
idée me paraît être de nature à répondre
à vos préoccupations sans pour étant
engendré les effets collatéraux que je
redoute et qui conduisent à ma réserve
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs je
vous c'est dans cet hémicycle en tant
qu'élu confrontés à la violence de plus
en plus prégnante au sein de la société
particulièrement sensible à l'exigence
accrue de sécurité exprimées par nos
concitoyens
je me réjouis donc de l'examen
aujourd'hui d'un texte qui valorise des
professions exposées
quasiment avec talent et abnégation des
fonctions de prévention de présence
dissuasive de médiation mais également
lorsque c'est nécessaire de contrôle et
de répression je ne doute pas du sort
que vous réserverez à ce texte équilibré
complet mûri et concertée qui aura j'en
suis certain un avenir au delà des bons
vins
hémicycle je remercie encore les
sénateurs et sénatrices qui sont
impliqués dans l'élaboration de ce texte
et je forme le voeu que le débat qui va
ce livre soit aussi riche que l'a été de
travail de préparation qui a sont
conduits à son évocation et au débat
d'aujourd'hui
merci monsieur le ministre dans la suite
de la discussion générale la parole est
à monsieur jean vincent placé pour le
groupe écologie
monsieur le président c'est ministre
madame la rapporteur de la commission
des lois mais chaque collègue je me
réjouis que nous soyons réunis
aujourd'hui afin de discuter de l'avenir
des polices municipales
un débat qui prolonge la réflexion que
j'ai pu moi même menés dans le cadre de
mon rapport spécial sur la sécurité le
budget la police et la gendarmerie au
nom de la commission des finances je
salue évidemment le travail de nos deux
collègues françois pillés et rené van
dieren noms qui ont su travailler de
concert éloigner des questions
partisanes ce qui les honneurs une
première fois en 2012 lors de la
rédaction de leur rapport d'information
sur la police municipale est aujourd'hui
avec cette proposition de loi qui en
découlent juste une petite remarque
liminaire mais c'est sûr que nous serons
tous d'accord pour le dire et compris
devant le ministre de l'intérieur notre
souci
notre inquiétude quant aux moyens
primordiaux prioritaire que doivent
avoir la police et la gendarmerie police
et gendarmerie qui assume la fonction
régalienne sur l'ensemble du territoire
national pour la sécurité des biens et
des personnes de nos compatriotes donc
c'est évidemment le souci prioritaire et
les polices municipales
pendant de nombreuses années l'on sait
la polémique je peux même faire sur les
effectifs de la police et la gendarmerie
soutient qu'elle un précédent ça s'est
amélioré restaurer évidemment depuis
deux ans et je sais que dans l'objectif
quinquennal du président la république
françois hollande je suis sûr monsieur
le ministre que vous consulterez
continuerait le travail de votre
prédécesseur quant à la restauration des
effectifs de la police et de la
gendarmerie pour avoir une présence
normal proportionnelle et équitable sur
l'ensemble de nos territoires qu'ils
soient d'ailleurs urbains et ruraux je
vois le sourire de louis mais je
suis sûr qu'ils apprécient qui est plus
de policiers plus de gendarmes dans les
alpes maritimes et cela depuis deux ans
donc cette police municipale ne doit pas
être un palliatif et ne doit pas
naturellement remplacé les fonctions les
objectifs l'activité de la police
nationale et la gendarmerie elle doit
avoir un une mission propre et cette
mission propre c'est tout simplement
évidemment d'assurer la sécurité et le
vivre ensemble ça ne doit pas être un
bras armé palliatifs moins efficace de
la police nationale la gendarmerie car
son rôle doit être complémentaire et non
subsidiaire cette mission notamment liés
à la prévention et à la dissuasion doit
être dans une perspective de
préservation de la tranquillité et de la
salubrité comme le précise d'ailleurs
extrêmement utilement l'article 13 de
cette proposition de loi je reviendrai
sur le sujet dans mon petit propos bien
sûr dans ces conditions je le dis tout
de même à ce moment de la discussion la
mission la police nationale ne me semble
en aucun cas imposer que celles ci
soient dotés d'armes de 4ème catégorie
je le dis car je sais que cela fait
débat et je pense que c'est bien de le
dire à ce moment là
sur le débat qui est le nôtre plus
globalement j'ai conscience que le vrai
débat est ici celui de la coopération
entre les acteurs publics la sécurité et
non du roule même de la police
municipale qui est acté de longue date
mais je me permets néanmoins de rap et à
fusion qui est proposé ici entre les
agents de police municipale et les
gardes champêtres ne change
évidemment pas notre position de fond
nous les écologistes sur le rôle des
agents de la police municipale ou
territoriale et donc notre position je
viens de le réaffirmer à ce qu'ils
soient armés dans leur mission de
proximité auprès des citoyens je
souhaite d'ailleurs dans cette
discussion vivement salué l'effort de
cette proposition de loi de rôle de
rendre tout son rôle aux gardes
champêtres dans les circonstances
actuelles de déclin du nombre de gardes
champêtres et intéressant d'envisager
une fusion des deux statues accompagné
d'une formation de tous les agents aux
enjeux de protection
des espaces naturels de biodiversité et
de lutte contre les délits
environnementaux
je peux y voir là en étant positif un
renforcement de la police
environnementale que j'appelle de mes
voeux le volet formation de ce texte
prend ici tout son sens et le ministre
vient de le rappeler et nous insistons
pour qu'il se penche sérieusement sur la
formation aux enjeux environnementaux
que ce soit sur le littoral que ce soit
dans le rural que ce soit dans le
forestier c'est extrêmement important
formation à l' usage de larmes je ne le
répèterai jamais assez il serait
bénéfique elle s'accompagne surtout
d'une formation leur non usage à une
fois encore afin de se concentrer sur le
rôle préventif de la police territoriale
jusqu alors les polices municipales
instaurer la discrétion des mères
étaient trop souvent d'ailleurs le
reflet des inégalités entre les communes
pauvres et riches les communes pauvres
subissent ainsi une double peine celle
de ne pouvoir financer une police
municipale et je vois j'entends les
approbations du maire de
clichy-sous-bois l'ancien maire de
clichy-sous-bois chers collègues et donc
cela me fait plaisir donc et de
bénéficier dans la même condition était
comme une riche du soutien la police
nationale en raison du principe
d'égalité donc on a l'impression que les
commissariats sont déjà dans les zones
riches évidemment au regard des finances
locales on ne peut pas avoir de police
municipale c'est donc la double peine et
donc c'est en ce sens que je vois de
façon extrêmement positive le volet
mutualisation les communes vont ainsi
gagner en efficacité
mais pour cela il faut que la
mutualisation ne soit pas seulement
entendu comme un transfert de
compétences mais plutôt comme une
optimisation des moyens et elle ne doit
pas s'accompagner non plus d'une
extension des pouvoirs des agents de
police territoriale le débat ça
mutualisation et non pas l'extension des
pouvoirs de police territoriale et à cet
égard je salue l'ambition de mettre en
place une police territorialisée qui
s'appuie sur une grande connaissance des
quartiers et sur une relation de
confiance et de proximité avec les
habitants nous avons eu déjà le débat
sur la question la police de proximité
qui avait été supprimée également par
nos prédécesseurs
la mutualisation des moyens de police à
l'échelle intercommunale
permettra je l'espère de développer une
réflexion sur la cohésion territoriale
et sur l'aménagement des missions de
sécurité à l'échelle des territoires et
c'est là un autre débat
vous l'aurez compris dans mon
intervention que je conclus les
écologistes de par leur position
historique sur la question d'un police
municipale des soient municipales ou
territoriales ne serait pas ne seront
pas en situation d'apprécier cette
proposition noir qui est qui a sa
cohérence et sa cohésion mais je tiens à
le dire nous allons nous abstenir au
regard des éléments extrêmement
intéressants qui ont été apportées pour
assumer davantage la question la
sécurité au plus près des territoires et
en termes de proximité et pour faire en
sorte que nous soyons et je tiens
vraiment là dessus assure ce sujet a
salué les coauteurs de les deux co
auteurs de ce texte de loi je crois que
nous sommes ici sur l'importance d'avoir
le bicamérisme mais d'importants avoirs
un sénat qui peut s'éloigner des
questions partisanes de pouvoir
travailler tous ensemble pour l'intérêt
général et globalement ça va plutôt dans
le bon sens que dans le mauvais ce texte
merci à vous merci monsieur le président
la parole est à madame catherine train
de l'est pour le groupe ump
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre madame le rapporteur mes chers
collègues la proposition de loi que nous
allons examiner aujourd'hui fait suite
au rapport d'information de 2012 de nos
collègues françois pilé et rené
vandierendonck dont la plupart des
recommandations ont été intégrés faisant
le bilan des 25 ans de la police
municipale ce rapport mettait en avant
les difficultés qu'elles rencontrent
aujourd'hui encore une confusion des
compétences entre les forces de police
municipale étatique qui conduit nos
concitoyens à eghezée a exigé beaucoup
des forces de police locales une
judiciarisation des polices municipales
réquisitionné parfois par le procureur
de la république pour certaines
interventions
il ya également des engagements étatique
qui conduit la police municipale à
s'éloigner de ses missions de prévention
et de proximité
enfin un accroissement des inégalités en
matière de sécurité selon les moyens de
chaque collectivité
pour donner un nouveau souffle à la
police locale pour proposer de remédier
à toutes ces difficultés en proposant
deux axes de réformes une
homogénéisation des polices locales
d'une part et une mutualisation de ces
nouvelles forces de police au niveau
intercommunal d'autre part tout cela
afin de favoriser l'émergence d'une
véritable police territoriale
l'objectif poursuivi vise comme vous
l'avez rappelé à fusionner dans un même
cadre d'emploi les agents de police
municipale et les gardes champêtres
s'ensuivrait alors dans une logique de
clarté un regroupement de l'ensemble des
compétences exercées par l'une et
l'autre de ces deux forces de police de
plus puisque la police territoriale
disposera des compétences actuellement
exercées par les gardes champêtres il
est évident que les régions les
départements les établissement public
chargé de la gestion d'un parc naturel
régional
garderont la faculté de recrutement de
policiers territoriaux dans ce domaine
il est certain qu en redonnant de la
lisibilité à la police locale nous
faciliterons regroupement des forces de
police au niveau de l'intercommunalité
il est vrai d'ailleurs que cette
mutualisation est indispensable d'abord
pour éviter l'abandon de certaines zones
rurales parfois très vaste où les
municipalités n'ont pas les moyens
d'assumer une force de police de grande
ampleur qui leur est pourtant
indispensable
pour cela vous proposez très justement
d'améliorer les dispositifs actuels
existants les conseils locaux de
sécurité les conventions de coordination
l'article 18 renverse en effet l'ordre
de création des conseils de sécurité de
prévention de la délinquance dans les
communes de plus de 10 mille habitants
ou comprenant une zone urbaine sensible
actuel actuellement lorsqu'il existe un
conseil local de sécurité et de
prévention de la délinquance la création
d'un conseil intercommunal de sécurité
et de prévention de la délinquance est
facultative vous proposez ainsi que la
création dans celle spd ne soit plus
possible c'est un cispd et créer ce qui
est une modification cohérente avec
l'évolution de notre droit des
collectivités
ceci afin de développer l'essor d'une
politique de prévention de la
délinquance à l'échelle intercommunale
l'article 19 l'article 19 de son côté
prévoit que le procureur de la
république sera signataire de la
convention de coordination également
signée par le maire par le préfet alors
qu'il ne donnait jusque alors qu'un avis
sur cette convention dès lors que la
police municipale connaît un
accroissement important de ces pouvoirs
judiciaires il est en effet
indispensable de donner les moyens à
l'autorité judiciaire de mieux contrôler
l'exercice de ses pouvoirs
mais ce n'est pas tout cette convention
entend également reconnaître le travail
décisif menée par les policiers en leur
reconnaissant une véritable initiative
dans la rédaction de cette convention de
coordination et nous nous en
satisfaisons enfin sur ce point la
commission des lois judicieusement
abaisser le seuil rendant obligatoire la
conclusion de la convention de
coordination à quatre emplois d'agents
de police territoriale au lieu des 5
actuellement est prévue une période
transitoire de trois ans à contrer
compter de l'entrée en vigueur de la loi
lorsque les services de police
territoriale de plus de quatre agents
ont été créés avant l'entrée en vigueur
de la disposition durant cette période
ces services pourront poursuivre leur
activité
au-delà de ces deux outils juridiques le
dont le fonctionnement était amélioré le
texte prévoit une amélioration cohérente
du rôle joué par les établissements
publics dans les cordes coordination des
politiques de sécurité
alors d'abord l'article 16 qui fait du
président dans le pc à fiscalité propre
un officier de police judiciaire et
l'article 17 prévoit qu'en cas de
transfert de compétences en matière de
transports urbains un ep seuil et la
responsabilité de la police des
transports sous réserve de l'accord de
l'ensemble des communes concernées et du
président de l'établissement public de
coopération intercommunale
si cet accord peut représenter en
théorie certaines difficultés le texte
prévoit en fait une contrepartie pour
les présidents de pc puisque
l'intercommunalité pourra refuser le
transfert de compétences afférentes en
somme
rationalisation et mutualisation sont
donc les mots d'ordre de cette réforme
qui doit donc être approuvé mais avant
de conclure je tiens à intervenir sur
l'une des particularités du haut-rhin
celle du syndicat mixte des gardes
champêtres intercommunaux plus
communément appelée la brigade verte
c'est la loi d'amélioration de la
décentralisation du 5 janvier 1988 qui a
repris à son article 44 un amendement
proposé par le sénateur goetschy auquel
s'étaient alors associer les sénateurs
schielé et enel cet amendement
permettent un regroupement de
collectivités réunies dans un syndicat
mixte d'avoir en commun des gardes
champêtres compétent sur l'ensemble des
territoires des communes constituant ce
groupement
depuis la mise en application de ces
dispositions les gardes champêtres ont
alors constitue un véritable corps pour
le aura
placé sur l'autorité juridique bien
évidemment de leur mère ils ont comme
cadre de gestion à syndicat mixte comme
je les dix regroupements regroupant part
dans des communes le département du haut
rhin ainsi que le cas échéant des
syndicats de communes ou de district une
soixantaine de garde champêtre répartis
sur dix postes du département sont ainsi
déployés sur le territoire de 3 113
communes sur les 377 que comporte le
département les patrouilles sont
effectuées 7 jours sur 7 365 jours par
an la brigade verte travaille en
partenariat avec toutes les autres
institutions du territoire est entre
autres la région alsace le conseil
général la gendarmerie la police il
s'agit pour les habitants du haut rhin
de l'un des piliers de leur sécurité de
retrancher lité
cette organisation fonctionne très bien
et répond parfaitement aux besoins entre
autres des petites communes en
répartissant les coûts entre les
communes les intercommunalités et le
département
la brigade verte étant unique sur le
territoire national de la de par la
dimension de son intercommunalité et de
son financement il est certain que le
projet de police territoriale remet en
cause son mode de fonctionnement et par
la même occasion une structure qui a su
répondre aux attentes de nos concitoyens
du haut rhin ainsi que des élus dont les
collectivités prennent part à cette
organisation
alors compte tenu de ces éléments vous
l'aurez compris monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues je n'ai eu de cesse de
plaider pour la prise en compte du
maintien de cette spécificité propre
aura
en résumé et j'y reviendrai tout à
l'heure en résumé mes chers collègues il
existe certes un véritable consensus sur
ce texte tant sur le constat des limites
rencontrées par la police municipale
actuellement que sur les moyens de lui
donner un nouveau souffle et je
terminerai en rappelant que le travail
fourni du rapport d'information de nos
collègues françois pilé et rené
vendirent donc n'y est pas pour rien et
je tiens au nom de mon groupe à les
saluer je vous remercie
merci madame la présidente la parole est
à monsieur vincent capo-canellas ce pour
le groupe udi uc
pour lire
monsieur le président monsieur ministre
c'est le vice-président de la commission
des lois madame le rapporteur mes chers
collègues j'ai déjà eu l'occasion lors
du débat qui a fait suite au rapport de
nos collègues 21dans képi les d'indiquer
l'orientation générale de mon groupe sur
le sujet des polices municipales et sur
ce rapport en premier lieu j'ai salué le
pragmatisme des auteurs il est utile de
reconnaître le rôle des polices
municipales en complémentarité avec
l'état dans l'effort de coproduction de
sécurité et je rappellerai ici en tant
que maire d'une commune de banlieue en
seine-saint-denis et combien face à ce
grand défi de l'insécurité vécues par
nos concitoyens comme un fléau nous
devons faire assaut de pragmatisme et
essayer en tant que législateur mais
aussi en tant que représentant des élus
locaux
de mettre en place l'ensemble des moyens
qui concourent à plus de sécurité
c'est bien évidemment l'enjeu dans le
respect du rôle de chacun privilégier
une approche pragmatique plutôt
idéologique dans ce domaine de la
sécurité est en soi un point qu'il faut
apprécier à sa juste valeur avec ce que
cela peut représenter de conversion au
réel pour certains tant mieux recrue
reconnaître pleinement les polices
municipales admettre le rôle utile dcs
ulysse en eau supervision urbaine non
môssieur ministre a justement parlé tout
à l'heure c'est une conversion au réel
c'est positif aussi je vous dirais que
dans ce rapport ce qui nous intéresse
autant ils nous avaient ré plutôt ce
rapport au temps parce qu'ils
comportaient comme changement que parce
qu'il ne comportait pas c'est à dire pas
trop de remises en cause
je salue donc en premier lieu votre
pragmatisme et veux redire ici mon
profond respect pour l'ensemble des
forces de l'ordre qui agissent au
quotidien pour la sécurité de nos
concitoyens
j'aurai un mot tout particulier bien sûr
pour ceux qui sont concernés par cette
proposition de loi des policiers
municipaux mais je n'oublie que la
production sécurité est une coproduction
et c'est donc à tous les agents de
police au sens large qui nous font nous
adresser en n'oubliant pas le prix
qu'ils paient chaque année avec des
blessés et parfois des morts nous avons
tous en tête des drames dans le
consensus 4 recueils le travail ex
éléments engagés par les rapporteurs il
faut quand même rappeler une évidence
ici et je n'ai entendu en filigrane
lorsque jean vincent placé s'est exprimé
tout à l'heure les maires en viennent à
créer des polices municipales lorsqu'ils
ont perdu l'espoir de voir des effectifs
de police nationale suffisant pour faire
face à la délinquance et il met en place
un service qui vient en complémentarité
avec l'état ils le font avec
responsabilité en prenant pleinement en
compte la responsabilité et l'engagement
nouveau keller ce que ça va demander au
quotidien et les risques que cela
représente
et
l'utilité des polices municipales est
réel je veux dire comme représentant du
secteur urbain que chez nous avec des
taux délinquance qui parfois frise les
100 pour 1000 habitants le travail de
tissage du lien de ratissage du lien
avec la population de détection de
présence de terrain de remontée
d'informations mais aussi de
partenariats avec des services enquêtent
parfois leur demande lorsqu'un csu est
bien menée et marche bien elle semble
supervision urbaine fourni à la police
nationale et service enquêtes
spécialisées des éléments de preuves
considérables et j'ai eu l'occasion dans
ma commune de faire baisser la
délinquance de 30% j'ai peut-être la
chance de pas voir
j'avais des faits importants 95 pour
mille on est retombé à 65 pour mille
mais c'était pas d'effets de grande
délinquance mais c'était beaucoup de
délinquance malgré tout il en reste
encore donc c'est dans cette logique de
pragmatisme europe stabilité je crois
qu'il faut regarder ces différents
sujets et salué le fait que les polices
municipales se sont professionnalisés et
lorsque les hommes travaillent bien
ensemble
hommes et femmes police nationale police
municipale dans le respect du rôle de
chacun il peut y avoir une coproduction
extrêmement utile face à des défis et
face à une délinquance qui est toujours
changeante vente et vis à vis de
laquelle nous devons nous adapter bien
évidemment alors avec pragmatisme vous
avez proposé des ajouts des compléments
aux droits existants en matière de
formation en matière d'avancement en
matière d'agrément mieux encadrer et
mieux cadrer le rôle des asvp le rôle
des opérateurs de ces su tout cela son
temps fort bien les conventions de
coordination police municipale oui
nationale sont un outil dont il ne faut
pas exagérer la portée mais qui peuvent
être utiles le rééquilibrage recherché
est positif je mets là dessus un petit
bémol quand même attention le
partenariat est avant tout une affaire
d'hommes on va pas tout codifié dans des
conventions et tout fonctionne bien si
les hommes s'entendent le commissaire de
police et la brise ationale a un rôle
éminent et la police municipale fournit
des moyens mais elle n'est pas là y
compris en matière d'ordre public pour
décider et le maire n'est pas là pour
décider dans ce cadre-là la conduite des
opérations se fait sous l'autorité du
commissaire c'est un équilibre n'est pas
simple et qu'il nous faut savoir garder
donc il y a quand même dans tout cela un
certain nombre de points de débat je
crois à la complémentarité mais je veux
dire sur les points de débat
l'intercommunale isation nous conduit à
changer le nom la dénomination des
polices municipales pour en faire des
polices territoriale j'ai déjà dit en
commission
vraiment combien j'étais sceptique par
rapport à ce changement d'appellation il
me semble que l'apport est extrêmement
limité mais que la soustraction est réel
je proposerai tout à l'heure par
amendement que l'on donne de la
souplesse aux communes est que lorsqu
elles le souhaitent elles puissent
décider de garder l'appellation de
police municipale la police territoriale
crée ainsi par cette proposition de loi
peut prendre l'appellation de police
municipale lorsque le conseil municipal
décide elle et territoriales mais elle
s'appellera police municipale et je
pense que c'est utile le sujet me semble
ne pas être seulement symbolique
d'abord cette manie que nous avons dans
les textes plutôt que de faire autre
chose de changer les noms cette manie là
elle a un coot elle exaspère sur le
terrain y at il une bonne raison de
changer
de quelque chose qui fonctionne je n'en
vois pas je pense que ce texte en plus
d'un portera pas dans les villes qui ont
déjà une police municipale une
révolution autre que le nom il faudra
expliquer aux agents pourquoi et les
agents pour qui la question de
l'appellation a un sens particulier ce
sont des services d'autorité qui aiment
bien savoir qui répondent et ne
répondent pas à un vague territoire ils
répondent au maire et ils sont au final
payé par la commune je pense aussi c'est
une claire distinction avec les services
de l'état parce que le nom de police
municipale signifie bien qu'on n'est pas
dans le cas de la police nationale
l'appellation est bien clair me
semble-t-il dans les deux cas donc un
peu de souplesse là dessus j'irai en
dernier lieu sur ce point là que la
police municipale suppose un effort
financier on l'a évoqué l'état leur
apportant pour les communes et que dès
lors il n'est pas inutile qu'elle porte
ce nom là municipale parce que l'impôt
vient de là est un peu de visibilité ne
lui pas
sur ce point je vais pas être beaucoup
plus long puis je vois le temps qui file
un petit peu froid il faut prendre garde
à ne pas tomber dans l'eau si dans le
piège d'une restriction des pouvoirs des
polices municipales des objectifs qui
leur sont données elle doit s'inscrire
dans une complémentarité avec la police
nationale et pouvoir ainsi participer à
l'information de la position nationale à
la remontée les témoignages et notamment
quant au csu il faut qu'on ait
conscience que le csu permet d'observer
de renseigner les prix national de
prévenir la délinquance et de fournir
des éléments de preuve attention à ne
pas dériver sur ce point prenons garde à
ne pas spécialisés la police municipale
non plus trop sur les pouvoirs de police
du maire bien sûr elle aborde là pour ça
mais en vertu de l'article 40 était là
se pratique aujourd'hui elle est tenue
aussi de transmettre à la police
nationale un certain nombre
d'informations et de concourir à des
enquêtes idem sur l'armement attention
exposé des agents suppose des moyens la
sérigraphie j'en ai évoqué un mot tout à
l'heure également je crois qu'il ya un
acquis et que changer aussi les couleurs
la typologie des terrasses avaeint
énervé tout le monde localement
deuxièmement la police municipale elle y
compris aujourd'hui elle est identifiée
à quoi bon changer les couleurs je
comprends qu'on veuille se distinguer la
bouée nationale je retiens fait
aujourd'hui ça marche ça fonctionne
pourquoi changer ce qui fonctionne voilà
je vais simplement terminer monsieur
ministre en vous disant que ce sujet est
un sujet à l'intérêt général que les qui
vibre et complexes et j'aurai l'occasion
dans le cadre des amendements de revenir
sur un certain nombre de points
pragmatisme efficacité apportons à des
plus et veillant à ne pas déstabiliser
un édifice qui parfois peut quand même
paraître fragile et surtout dans des
territoires où la délinquance est forte
veillant à ce que tout le monde continue
à travailler ensemble c'est je crois
l'essentiel au mercy mercy la parole est
à mme adam eliane assassi pour le groupe
crc
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
madame la rapporteure mes chers
collègues donc 25 ans après
l'officialisation des des polices
municipales la mission d'information à
l'origine de cette proposition de loi
consacré à cette police de tranquillité
publique menée il faut le reconnaître
avec rigueur et sérieux par nos
collègues françois pinet et rené
vandierendonck avait pour objet de
s'interroger sur l' équilibre général
des dispositions législatives et
réglementaires en vigueur les deux
rapporteurs avait d'ailleurs conclu
leurs travaux en formulant donc 25
préconisations ayant pour ambition je
les cite d'adapter le régime juridique
des polices municipales et favoriser un
fonctionnement et un emploi plus
efficient de ses services ils ont
surtout commencé par dresser le constat
des dérives qui découlent du
désengagement progressif de l'état en
matière de sécurité dans nos communes
des rives qui touchent au fondement même
de notre république pour reprendre leurs
propres termes nous adhérons totalement
à ce constat d'autant que à maintes
reprises notamment ici dans cet
hémicycle nous avions dénoncé ce
désengagement est à l'acte et sur ses
conséquences
donc le rapport dénonce à juste titre la
diminution progressive des effectifs de
police nationale au cours des dernières
années et le retrait des forces
régaliennes du territoire que les maires
de doute de tous bords n'est ce pas
monsieur je vois que vous me
regardez pas ce que vous attendiez
quelque chose mais je le je le dis avec
force de tout bord soucieux de la
sécurité des citoyens sont contraints de
compenser par le renforcement de leurs
services de police municipale et nous
élus constatent chaque jour les
conséquences de cet abandon qu'ils se
voient qu'ils entraînent pour tous pour
les budgets locaux des charges
supplémentaires auxquelles ils ne
peuvent souvent serfass qu'avec
difficulté ainsi par exemple à chaque
fois qu'il est fait appel par nécessité
à des services de sécurité privés c'est
notre service public qui en pâtit alors
quoi de plus alors alarmant que d'être
obligé de pallier la compétence
régalienne de l'état en matière de
sécurité de paix d'ordre public de
protection des personnes et des biens
par le recours à des services privés
dont le seul objectif faut-il le
rappeler est quand même la rentabilité
alors je les dis et je le répèterai
encore la sécurité et la sphère de
l'état qui doit entièrement la prendre
en charge financièrement ce qui
n'empêche pas une application des élus
locaux mais en aucun cas elle ne doit
peser sur les municipalités alors à la
lecture de cette proposition de loi
permettez moi mes chers collègues de
vous dire ma déception car à l'afp
finalement choisi de nier le constat du
désengagement de l'état et les
dispositions qu'elle contient ses forces
au contraire de le pérenniser celle par
exemple de l'article 19 sont
particulièrement révélatrice sur ce
point puisqu'elle prévoit une plus forte
implication du procureur de la
république je cite suite à
l'accroissement des pouvoirs judiciaires
des polices municipales ainsi qu'un
véritable partage entre forces de
sécurité nationale et la police
territoriale de la nature et des lieux
et des lieux des interventions alors là
encore je vais je les dis mais c'est
toujours bien c'est toujours pédagogique
ou
pour notre part notre ambition est bien
plus grande que ce simple aménagement
prévu dans ce texte pour éviter le
développement d'une sécurité à double
vitesse pour une réappropriation par
l'état de sa mission régalienne je suis
pour ma part mais les collègues de mon
groupe le sont tout autant favorable à
la création d'un grand service public où
seraient regroupées police municipale
police nationale et gendarmerie
nationale et où le rôle des différentes
forces seraient clairement définies dans
l'intérêt des citoyens comme des
policiers et cette ambition recueille
l'assentiment des personnels or nous en
sommes loin avec ce texte certes il
permet la fusion entre les policiers
municipaux et des gardes tempête ce que
nous partageons certes il permet l'accès
des policiers municipaux à certains
fichiers mais je voudrais dire que la
sar est son intérêt de celui des
citoyens comme de celui des prix et il
est fait peu de cas alors des comptes
des citoyens tout d'abord il est lu ta
ble ment vont perdurer les inégalités en
autres entre nos concitoyens devant la
sécurité en fonction des moyens dont
disposent les communes par ailleurs même
lorsque les communes en ont les moyens
les agents de police municipale se
trouvent par la force des choses qu'on
train d'accomplir de nouvelles missions
de répression dévolu en principe aux
forces nationales au détriment de leurs
missions traditionnelles de prévention
et de proximité pourtant essentiel et
cher là aussi à nos concitoyens pour les
policiers municipaux ensuite ces
derniers ont vu une évolution
spectaculaire de leur mission pendant
longtemps longtemps ils ont été
cantonnés à assurer la sécurité des
enfants à la sortie des écoles ou à
verbaliser les mauvais stationnements
alors peu à peu en raison de cette
démission de l'état leur fonction se
sont étoffés
on devine la pression supplémentaire qui
pèse sur ses policiers municipaux
on devine aussi le mal être de ces
policiers qui du fait des nouvelles
charges qu'ils subissent ont le
sentiment légitime de ne pas être
reconnus à leur juste valeur alors j'en
ai reçu un très grand nombre de leurs
représentants
dans un très large panel au moment de la
parution du rapport et pas plus tard
encore que la semaine dernière pour
discuter de cette proposition de loi et
je peux vous confirmer ce mal-être est
relayée ici leur insatisfaction devant
un texte qui fait encore une fois
l'impasse sur le volet social sur la
pénibilité sur leur rémunération
et sur leur retraite en effet avec un
salaire moyen légèrement supérieur à
1500 euros après 20 ans d'exercice et
moins de 1000 euros de retraite la
revalorisation de leurs droits sociaux
est à juste titre une attente forte des
syndicats et de l'ensemble des
personnels
ces personnels sont le service public
ce personnel ce sont tout simplement des
femmes d mon
des policiers du quotidien comme ils
s'appellent qui mérite que leurs
revendications sociales soient enfin
entendues alors mes chers collègues oui
nous espérions beaucoup et beaucoup plus
après l'excellent rapport de nos
collègues françois piller rené
vandierendonck et le non moins excellent
débat que nous avions eues ici même en
janvier 2013 mais malgré quelques
avancées je l' ai dit tout à l'heure qui
sont attendus notamment par les gardes
champêtres champêtre ce texte n'est pas
au rendez vous du souffle
du rapport de nos collègues c'est un
texte qui n'est pas abouti puis à
l'heure quant au débat sur l'appellation
police territoriale police municipale
avant de changer la dénomination encore
faudrait-il savoir de quel territoire il
s'agit puisque police territoriale à
l'aube de textes qui vont beaucoup nous
occuper ici au sénat d'ici quelque temps
je voudrais bien savoir ce que cela
suppose ce que cela veut dire je ne suis
pas sûr qu'on en sache beaucoup
aujourd'hui et je suis donc favorable à
ce qu'on en reste à l'appellation police
municipale pour l'heure donc vous
l'aurez compris je les dis ce texte
manque d'ambition mais il ya quelques
avancées si la raison pour laquelle nous
nous abstiendrons
merci madame la présidente la parole est
à madame anne marie escoffier pour le
groupe rds
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur préside la commission
des lois madame la rapporteuse
chers collègues je voudrais en tout
premier lieu saluer l'initiative de la
commission des lois qu'il y a près de
deux ans alors que la prétendue réforme
territoriale était encore dans les
limbes mais que les aménagements divers
et variés relatifs à la police à la
gendarmerie au code de la sécurité
intérieure au code pénal s'étaient
multipliées que cette commission des
lois avait demandé à nos deux excellent
collègue rené vandierendonck et françois
pilée de conduire unique sur l'évolution
de la police municipale évolution rendue
indispensable au regard de ces
aménagements
de leur travail confortée par les
conclusions du rapport d'information de
monsieur lambert detraigne mezara sido
fait au nom de la délégation aux
collectivités territoriales en mai 2010
est issu la proposition de loi que nous
examinons aujourd'hui une proposition
qui a le mérite de clarifier
des dispositions devenues complexes au
fur et à mesure de l'accumulation de
textes ici il s'agit vraiment d'un
millefeuille bien différent de celui
auquel on voudrait nous faire croire
s'agissant de la réforme territoriale
une proposition qui veut donner une
nouvelle unité à la police nationale
municipale en donnant sens à son
organisation et son fonctionnement
et cela en complémentarité avec les
forces de sécurité qu'elles soient de
police ou de gendarmerie
je veux saluer les dispositions de pur
bon sens qui unifie dans le même cadre
d'emploi police municipale et gardes
champêtres et d'un véritable cadre
juridique d'intervention aux agents de
surveillance de la voie publique et aux
assistants temporaire des agents de
police municipale
je veux aussi me féliciter de la place
tel qu'affirmé
la formation dont bénéficieront de façon
adaptée à leur charge les fonctionnaires
municipaux
enfin je veux dire combien me paraît
judicieuse la disposition de l'article
19 relative au régime des conventions de
coordination
conclu entre le préfet et le maire après
avis du procureur de la république ait
tendance à un rééquilibrage des
obligations entre les différentes forces
de sécurité dans une véritable politique
de coproduction de la sécurité comme
vous l'avez rappelé monsieur le ministre
en revanche
et c'est là tout le sens des amendements
déposés par mes amis du groupe rds je ne
peux me résoudre à voir le qualificatif
territoriales se substituer à celui de
municipal quelle étrange manière que de
vouloir tout faire passer par le mot
territoriales comme si nos municipalités
d'hier d'aujourd'hui et dès demain
encore je l'espère n'avait plus
d'existence la référence aux polices
municipales
tout son sens
pour nos concitoyens et ce n'est pas
parce que ces fonctionnaires sont
employés par exemple aux salins parc
naturel régional qu'ils perdraient leur
identité oublierait ton que les
dispositions existent bel et bien déjà à
l'article 22 12 5 du code général des
collectivités territoriales pour
organiser au sein des communes
volontaires les mutualisations
nécessaires au bon fonctionnement des
services identifiés au sein des parcs
des régions ou des départements sans
qu'il soit prévu de changer nous disait
notre ami 26 ans donc tout à l'heure
d'un iota le rôle du maire serait ce
raisonnable à l'heure où personne ne
connaît le devenir des régions réduite à
quatorze et doubler périmètre et encore
moins celui du département disparaîtra
disparaîtra pas à l'horizon 2021
2015-2020 de modifier cet intitulé de
police municipale devenu familier à tout
à chacun
je ne retiens que pour l'anecdote est
pourtant qu'à vouloir changer un nom le
législateur modifierait une norme qui
viendrait s'ajouter aux 400 milles
normes dont on voudrait réduire le
nombre et le coût de 15 millions si j'ai
bien compris et qui aujourd'hui
représente 1 milliard 200 millions par
an je ne me résoudrai pas davantage à
accepter la nouvelle
énumération de pouvoir du maire
élargi à la tranquillité la prévention
la surveillance du bon ordre et fort
heureusement débarbouiller d'une notion
de moralité dont la portée du mérite et
d'abondants commentaire tout comme celle
de commodités de la voie publique la
compétence des maires en matière de
police municipale et chose trop sérieuse
pour qu'une réflexion approfondie ne
soit pas indispensable avant toute
tentative de réécriture
enfin je soutiendrai l'amendement de
suppression de l'article 18 qui a
interdit la coexistence du conseil local
de sécurité et de prévention de la
délinquance et d'un conseil
intercommunal de même nature mais
élargie j'observe que l'article l 132
cas du code de la sécurité intérieure
nous vrai qu'une possibilité et non une
obligation et que c'était là le moyen de
mieux répondre par une solution adaptée
aux problèmes recueillies sur le terrain
madame le rapporteur monsieur le
ministre vous me voyez très attachés
comme les collègues notamment ceux du
rds à trouver des modes de
fonctionnement harmonieux et harmonisée
dans tous les domaines de l'action
publique susceptible de servir nos
concitoyens améliorer le fonctionnement
et l'organisation des polices
municipales est en soi une ambition à
laquelle j'adhère même si ici je pense
que l'on aurait pu aller plus loin par
exemple s'agissant de l'accès à des
fichiers réglementaires ou à la
mutualisation mais une telle
amélioration à un prix celle des
amendements proposés par mon groupe et
qui conditionneront notre accord merci
madame la parole est à monsieur philippe
quatelbach que pour le groupe socialiste
monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre
madame le rapporteur mes chers collègues
à l'automne 2012 nos collègues rené
vandierendonck et françois piller
rendait public leurs recommandations
qu'il avait formulées dans le cadre de
leur mission d'information sur les
polices municipales
plusieurs d'entre elles et non des
moindres ont été reprises dans le cadre
de la proposition de loi qui nous
soumettent ce jour une nouvelle fois ne
pouvons que nous féliciter que les
travaux conduits par le sénat trouvent
rapidement une traduction législative
cela montre à ceux qui en doutent que le
sénat travaille et que le sénat est
utile à notre république
commençons par un rapide état des lieux
les effectifs des polices municipales
représentent aujourd'hui un peu moins de
10% des effectifs cumulés de la police
nationale sont treize mille agents et de
la gendarmerie 94 mille agents nous
avons aujourd'hui environ 18000
policiers municipaux qui exercent leurs
missions dans 3000 commune ils étaient
quatre fois moins il ya 30 ans
ces quelques chiffres
montrent que aujourd'hui la police
municipale correspond à une réalité
concrète dans nos communes et qu'elle
est très différente suivant les communes
en effet moins d'une dizaine de communes
compte en france des effectifs de police
municipale supérieur à 100 agents quand
dans le même temps la moitié des villes
qui en sont dotés dispose dans se la
joue
cette grande hétérogénéité se retrouve
également au niveau des équipements et
notamment du type d'armement dont sont
dotés ces agents elle s'observe aussi au
niveau des missions confiées aux polices
municipales
dans de nombreuses communes les agents
de police municipale ont une activité de
police administrative effectuée deux
jours tels que par exemple la
surveillance des marchés dans votre
commune les agents effectuent de
véritables missions de sécurité publique
parfois même la nuit intervenant en
complément et j'ai envie de dire
parfois est peut-être trop souvent à la
place des services de l'état
c'est en raison de ses importants
contraste qu'il convient de ne pas
déroger aux principes selon lesquels les
polices municipales interviennent en
complément de la police nationale ou de
la gendarmerie nationales
pour les socialistes seules les forces
régaliennes sont en effet à même
d'assurer l'égalité de tous les citoyens
en matière de sécurité sur l'ensemble du
territoire et devrait efficacement
contre les agissements des criminels et
délinquants car nous le savons tous ces
agissements ne s'arrête pas aux
frontières des communes
alors il ya eu malheureusement une
érosion très forte des effectifs de
police nationale et devant la mairie
durant les deux précédents quinquennat
et même si cette érosion a été stoppée
avec le changement de majorité et
l'arrivée de renforts très attendu dans
les commissariats et les gendarmeries
nous le savons les maires de france ont
été confrontés à ces diminutions
importantes d'effectifs et je tiens
d'ailleurs à remercier
l'actuel ministre comme le précédent
d'avoir maintenu cette priorité de
renforcer les effectifs des forces
régaliennes moi je les ai connus en tant
que maire de clamart où quand j'ai été
élu en 2001 il avait 130 agents affectés
au commissariat et en 2011 il en restait
97 on voit donc que l'érosion a été très
forte dans les commissariats
cela dit il faut que la police
municipale ne remplace pas la présence
de l'état elle a en effet vocation à
accompagner les forces régaliennes et
dans la mesure où les effectifs de
celles ci peuvent souvent s'avérer
insuffisant l'a déchargé des tâches
annexes afin de lui permettre de se
concentrer sur les missions qui ne
seraient incomber à des services
municipaux
il y à votre pays un droit à la sécurité
nos concitoyens sont extrêmement
sensible sur cette question et c'est
vrai que l'augmentation de la
délinquance notamment celles touchant
les personnes renforce ce besoin de
sécurité il s'agit d'un principe
d'égalité républicaine qui était
essentielle et que nous devons préserver
alors oui je le dis si les socialistes
un pardon si l'état venait un jour à
s'en remettre très largement aux
communes pour assurer la sécurité de nos
concitoyens nous serions tout de suite
confrontées selon les territoires à une
inadéquation entre les besoins et les
moyens il ya de grandes inégalités
on le voit déjà un petit peu les villes
disposant d'importantes ressources
fiscales pourrait se doter d'effectifs
adapté et en revanche les villes
disposant de peu de moyens serait bien
sûr démunis l'égalité républicaine ans
aurait rompu sur un point pourtant
primordial celui du droit à la sécurité
des personnes et des biens
je prends un exemple que je connais bien
celui de l'ile-de-france cette région
qui est très urbanisé concentre une
importante proportion de crimes et
délits commis en france du fait même de
cette organisation et j'ai regardé il se
trouve que justement les quatre communes
franciliennes qui sont les mieux dotés
en termes de polices municipales sont et
à son issue de mon département je vais
les sites est un royaume malmaison
levallois-perret puteaux et courbevoie
il nous échappe pas que ce ne sont pas
des communes où se concentrent fortement
la sécurité même s'il ya comme partout
des difficultés mais en revanche ce sont
des communes où se concentre la richesse
lié à l'activité économique
que ce soit à la défense ou juste à côté
pour rueil malmaison et levallois perret
et donc on le voit c'est clair et c'est
parlant lorsque les villes disposent de
ressources fiscales importantes et bien
ils ont les moyens d'avoir des polices
municipales
nombreuses et bien sûr une plus grande
efficacité dans la lutte contre la
délinquance c'est bien sûr injuste et il
ne faut pas bien sûr accroître ces
inégalités territoriales
alors posé ce principe et je crois qu'il
faut rappeler fortement j'ai entendu que
nos amis d'europe écologie les verts et
du groupe communiste avait également
insisté sur ce point
il faut le rappeler fortement mais cela
ne doit pas nous empêcher d'avoir
pleinement conscience de l'utilité et du
rôle essentiel que joue aujourd'hui les
polices municipales dont les missions de
service public à l'échelle communale
voir demande de plus en plus à l'échelle
intercommunale
les policiers municipaux sont des
acteurs aujourd'hui bien identifiés par
nos concitoyens ils jouissent souvent
d'une grande proximité avec les
habitants croient qu'il faut insister
sur cette proximité sûr comme l'a dit
madame à 106,7 police du quotidien parce
que c'est avant tout à cela que nos
concitoyens sont attachés lorsqu'on
parle de police municipale et c'est vrai
qu'il y ait qu il y aura toujours
malheureusement quelques dérives et
quelques cow boy mais cela ne doit pas
nuire à l'image des dix-huit policiers
municipaux qui remplissent leur mission
avec un très grand professionnalisme ce
lien il nous faut l'accompagner en
organisant mieux le fonctionnement des
polices municipales
c'est ce que propose cette proposition
de loi en créant des polices
territoriale
en intégrant dans le même cadre les
agents de police municipale et les
gardes champêtres
les missions de ces derniers seront
préservés l'objectif étant que toutes
les missions puisse demain être exercée
par l'ensemble des agents de ce nouveau
cadre d'emploi avec des avancées en
matière de formation le ministre on a
parlé un 400 m le temps de formation va
passer de 3 mois à 6 mois je crois que
c'est extrêmement positif comme les
futures évolutions de carrière qui leur
seront ouvertes alors il ya bien sûr
tout le débat sur le nom le débat a déjà
été largement engagé police territoriale
police municipale j'ai même entendu
police locale bon c'est vrai que c'est
un débat intéressant je ne crois pas
qu'il faille focaliser toutes nos
énergies
sur le nom ce qui compte c'est le
contenu c'est le fait qu'on organise
mieux les polices municipales et après
bien on verra
dans le débat ici au sénat dans la
navette avec l'assemblée vers quels
termes il faut s'arrêter - et en est
rien été maire pendant 13 ans je suis un
petit peu comme monsieur cazeneuve
sensibles aux aspects financiers
c'est vrai que si tout cela induit des
coûts importants pour les communes à un
moment où on peut pas dire qu'elle soit
bien doté je crois qu'on sera dans un
mauvais impôt donc prenons peut-être le
temps de bien y réfléchir mais quoi
qu'il en soit il faut également et je
sais que certains sénateurs socialistes
ont des amendements en ce sens bien
marquer la différence entre la police
nationale et les police territoriale
municipal local pour qu'il n'y ait pas
d'ambiguïté et de confusion dans
l'esprit de nos concitoyens
j'en viens maintenant à la rédaction
nouvelles de l'article l
2212-2 du code général des collectivités
territoriales qui définit les pouvoirs
de police générale du maire et qui
résulte d'une accumulation progressive
avec de nombreuses modifications
législatives les auteurs de la
proposition de loi ont donc également
souhaité clarifier cette rédaction et
c'est une très bonne chose par souci de
lisibilité l'énumération des compétences
et désormais ramassés en six motions
cardinal la tranquillité la sécurité la
salubrité publique la prévention la
survie et la surveillance du bon ordre
ainsi que la sûreté et la commodité de
la circulation sur la voie publique
également des efforts importants sont
faits en matière de formation et c'est
un enjeu est aujourd'hui essentiel pour
les polices municipales comme pour toute
la fonction publique territoriale
la délivrance de l'agrément du procureur
de la république et du préfet sera
désormais la conditionner à la
transmission des avis de fin de
formation initiale délivré par le
président du cnfpt et je crois que c'est
une avancée pour
s'assurer d'une bonne formation et d'une
bonne efficacité des agents de police
municipale
et puis la proposition de loi propose de
modifier le régime des conventions de
coordination
moi je suis favorable le groupe
socialiste également été la commission
des lois à ce que cette convention fasse
l'objet d'une signature par le procureur
de la république c'est d'ailleurs le cas
déjà dans des départements où le
procureur a déjà signé ces conventions
de coordination je ne crois pas que ce
soit source de lourdeur de
dysfonctionnement ou
d'ambiguïté je crois que lorsqu'on a des
acteurs qui travaillent ensemble qui
font de la coproduction en matière de
sécurité et j'adhère à ces au slogan la
sécurité cette affaire de tous cela peut
se traduire un moment par la signature
de l'ensemble des acteurs d'un document
commun et nous avons là je crois à
l'occasion de le faire avec cette
signature des conventions de
coordination il faut donner vraiment
toute sa force à ce partenariat qui est
indispensable si on veut faire reculer
l'insécurité
si on veut rassurer nos concitoyens il
faut vraiment mobiliser toutes les
forces la police la gendarmerie mais
également la justice et puis les
collectivités locales et que tout cela
se traduise par la signature de ces
conventions sera je crois extrêmement
positif un mot également sur les
fichiers pour dire que le groupe
socialiste soutient complètement les
amendements portés par la rapporteure et
validé par la commission des lois il
faut que les polices municipales et
accès au fichier
chez moi même proposé à propos des
conventions à travers des amendements
que ce ne soit pas que le maire qu'ils
soient
informés
signataires donc forcément informés mais
que le conseil municipal soit également
complètement informés des dispositions
de la convention parce que souvent ce
qu'on parle de sécurité on pense bien
sûr au maire mais le maire a aussi un
conseil municipal et je crois que sur
ces conventions qu'il y ait un débat au
conseil municipal n'est pas inutile ça
permet l'information et du conseil
municipal et par là même de l'ensemble
des citoyens
puis pourquoi pas également qu'il y ait
des évolutions à la convention pour
tenir compte de propositions qui aurait
été formulée lors des conseils
municipaux plus on associera d'acteurs
et là en l'occurrence les conseillers
municipaux plus on pourra vraiment avoir
sur la sécurité un consensus le plus
large possible et une capacité pour
mobiliser vraiment toutes les énergies
quelques mots pour me féliciter
également qu'on reconnaisse le travail
effectué par les asvp et qu'on leur
permette un accès à la formation qui
sera rendue obligatoire et puis
également que soient traitées les
assistants temporaire de police
municipale pour clarifier là aussi c'est
le travail de ses agents
il ya eu des évolutions ces dernières
années cette proposition de loi vient à
point nommé pour rappeler les règles et
bien encadrer l'exercice des missions de
ses agents
pour conclure
conclure je veux saluer l'excellent
travail des deux auteurs de la
proposition de loi qui ont su travailler
de manière consensuelle au delà des
clivages politiques salue également le
travail de la rapporteure
qui a permis d'enrichir encore la
proposition de loi sur ces questions de
sécurité n'ayons pas une vision
politique ou idéologique
ce ne sont pas
j'ai pas dis que c'est des gros mots
madame à 106 j'ai juste dit qu'il
fallait c'est de dépasser les clivages
politiques sur ces questions parce que
tous nos concitoyens sont attachés à la
sécurité et plus on pourra trouver des
solutions pragmatiques et efficaces
mieux tous les français s'en porteront
ça empêche pas sur certains points
qu'ils aient des divergences mais là sur
ce qui est contenu dans la proposition
de loi sur l'architecturé on voit qu'il
ya un consensus assez large je crois que
il faut s'en féliciter parce que c'est
ce qui permet également de notre pays
d'avancer je sais également que ce
travail a pu être réalisée grâce à l'
écoute des deux ministres qui se sont
succédé manuel valls et bernard
cazeneuve donc je tiens également à les
remercier remercier également
tous ceux qui ont contribué à
l'enrichissement du texte les syndicats
l'association des maires de france ou
encore la commission consultative des
polices municipales
l'ensemble de ce texte permettra de
mieux accompagner les police
territoriale dans l'exercice de leurs
missions quotidiennes au plus près des
habitants et de renforcer leur
complémentarité avec les forces
régaliennes tout ça grâce un partenariat
renouvelé aussi le groupe socialiste
soutiendra ses propositions de loi je
vous remercie
voilà pour l'examen de cette proposition
de loi sénatoriale qui vise la mise en
place d'une police territoriale police
qui fusionnerait donc le cadre d'emplois
de garde champêtre et celui de policier
municipal
vous l'avez vu hier après midi les
débats ont été relativement consensuelle
même s'il ya eu un débat sur le terme
même de police territoriale sur le fond
sur cette fusion de ces deux cadres
d'emplois et bien il y avait plutôt un
accord au sein du sénat pouvait toujours
voir et revoir toutes les séances sur
notre site sur publicsenat.fr prochain
rendez vous de l'actualité parlementaire
cet après midi à 16h30 pour 24 heures
sénat la séance présentée par delphine
girard très bonne journée sur des
chaînes parlementaires
moi